خبر صادم وصلنا للاسف الان نبا استشهاد
الزميل عبد الله علوان المعلق الصوتي
الفلسطيني مع عائلته في قصف لطيران الكين
في مدينه جباليه شمال القطاع هذا الخبر
صادم شخصيا بالنسبه لي لانه كان احد اعز
الاصدقاء وايضا احد افراد طاقم قناه شاهد
لتعرف اشتغلنا مع بعض فيديوهات كثيره ما
بين التاريخي الى الوثائقي الى الاخباري
حتى الفيديوهات المرئيه هو كان له نصيب
منها واشتغلنا مع بعض فيديوهات مرئيه فانا
اسال الله له الرحمه والمغفره وادعوكم
جميعا لقراءه الفاتحه الى روحه وايضا في
اخر تواصل بين اخي محمد السويدي الذي هو
ماسك اداره القناه مع الاخ عبد الله يعني
للاطمئنان على صحه عبد الله في ظل الاحداث
الاخيره ترك عبد الله رساله او ارسل رساله
صوتيه فيها عبره وكلمه مهمه جدا نسمعها
انا وانت ونقرا الفاتحه الى روح عبد الله
علوان وعائلته وكل الشهداء في قصف هذا
الكيان الغاصب والمحتل حياك الله يا
الحبيب الله يبارك فيك يا رب ربنا يفرج
الكرب عنا وعنكم عن كل الشعوب العربيه
نحن محتلون من اليهود وانتم محتلون من
حكامكم هذا هو
الواقع بارك الله انا المعلق الصوتي عبد
الله علوان معلق قناه ميدان ومتانه وقنوات
الجزيره وغيرها انتظروني انا وزميل عبد
اللطيف الوشلي وسنحت باقوى الاعمال
الصوتيه على قناه شاهد لتعرف حديثنا
القادم عن ولا خليها مفاجاه الوحش الذي
يسكن في احشاء المحيط ولا يستيقظ الا في
حرب نهايه العالم وانا عبد اللطيف الوشلي
انتظرونا في الاعمال القادمه المثيره انا
والزميل عبد الله علوان على قناه شاهد
لتعرف